n'avons pas encore reçu de la totalité
des promesses tenues ont fait on fait
avec
les factures ne sont pas arrivés donc on
tient le coup mais pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de problème on pense recevoir en
russie la semaine avant le tour la
totalité d'une somme promise et après le
tour je pense que les factures qui
auront vite au nord cette eau 2017 il
faut de plus cher mais c'est là je pense
que ils sont un peu plus chers vu la
conjoncture on a moins d'argent et
certaines factures il faut ajouter 20 %
sur certaines factures on peut pas et
ils passeront en musique la sécurité
l'hébergement les transports tout ça
c'est en augmentation
je pense que il faut savoir jongler on
va jouer avec ce qu'on a et les factures
qui vont tomber
vous avez trésorier inquiets ou la
routine s'est installée ça marchera on
aurait crié pas du tout on fait on fait
avec les rentrées vont entrer et puis
mon père on fera les sorties mais je
suis confiant y'a pas de problème on
essaie de limiter au maximum les dégâts